inching closer to a wider conflict cross
border skirmishes for a fourth
day the Lebanese group hasbullah
targeting Israeli troops from their
position near the village of
dyra an intense exchange of fire then
follows this is another guided missile
that we just heard now
so it seems we are currently witnessing
a an
attack
and so artillery from the Israeli side
guarded missiles from the Lebanese
side families Sheltering in their homes
unable to move some people were injured
after a shell hid their
home we heard the shelling and went down
for shelter then my son and daughter of
are both injured and as you see my house
is not liveable
anymore another neighborhood another
partially damaged
home we were sitting there was nothing
then we started hearing explosions a
couple of times then the ones on the
other side the Israelis started
bombarding it was horrifying I can't
describe it we're angry because our
houses were targeted this house took
years to build now it's destroyed in one
second we took women and children to
Safe locations and I'm planning to stay
here decades long ground rules to avoid
the conflict Vanishing with every Clash
across the border and with every
exchange of fire the danger of
escalating the conflict yet further into
the region Ali Hashim Al jaaz DEA South
Lebanon